AS PAULA NEWTON REPORTS,
PROTESTS EVEN ON THE STREETS OF
KABUL.
>> Reporter: DEFIANCE IN AFGHAN,
WOMEN PROTESTING AFTER THE
TALIBAN STRIPS YET ANOTHER
FREEDOM AWAY.
>> Translator: EVER SINCE THEY
HAVE SEIZED POWER ALL THE
PROJECTS HAVE BEEN AGAINST
WOMEN, THEY WANT TO ELIMINATE
WOMEN FROM THE FIELD OF SOCIETY
AND POLITICS.
>> Reporter: A NEW TALIBAN
DEGREE ORDERS ALL WOMEN TO COVER
THEIR FACES EXCEPT THEIR EYES IN
PUBLIC OR AROUND MEN WHO ARE NOT
CLOSE ADULT RELATIVES.
IT'S TO AVOID PROVOCATION THE
GROUP'S SPOKESMAN SAYS, ANY
WOMAN THAT DOES NOT COMPLY COULD
SEE HER MALE GUARDIAN JAILED OR
LOSE HIS JOB.
WHEN THE TALIBAN TOOK OVER LAST
YEAR, THEY PROMISED TO RESPECT
WOMEN'S RIGHTS WITHIN ISLAMIC
LAW.
SINCE LAST AUGUST, THEY HAVE
BARRED GIRLS FROM RETURNING TO
SCHOOL, BANNED WOMEN FROM
TRAVELING LONG DISTANCES WITHOUT
A MALE CHAPERONE AND PLACED
STRICT LIMITATIONS ON WHERE
WOMEN CAN WORK.
NOW, THIS LATEST DECREE, BECOMES
ANOTHER MEASURE CHIPPING AWAY
FROM WOMEN'S RIGHTS IN
AFGHANISTAN AND EARNING
CONDEMNATION FROM WESTERN
LEADERS.
>> NO COUNTRY CAN SUCCEED THAT
HOLDS BACK HALF OF ITS
POPULATION.
ITS WOMEN, IT'S GIRLS.
THE TALIBAN POLICIES TOWARD
WOMEN ARE AN AFRONT TO HUMAN
RIGHTS AND WE WILL CONTINUE TO
IMPARE THEIR RELATIONS WITH THE
INTERNATIONAL COMMUNITY.
>> THE STATE DEPARTMENT
SPOKESMAN SAID THE U.S. IS
WORKING WITH INTERNATIONAL
PARTNERS TO INFLUENCE THE
TALIBAN TO REVERSE RESTRICTIVE
RULES ON WOMEN, BUT THE WOMEN
SAID THAT THE CHANGES HAVE TO
COME FROM WITHIN.
>> I DON'T WANT ANYTHING FROM
THE COUNTRIES OF THE WORLDS,
FROM THE GOVERNMENTS, BECAUSE
THEY WERE PROMISE AND THAT
PROMISE IS NEVER GOING TO TAKE
PLACE AND I HAVE SEEN IT.
THIS IS THE TIME FOR THE MEN OF
AFGHANISTAN TO STAND NEXT TO THE
WOMEN.
DON'T YOU THINK IT'S ABOUT TIME
THEY SHOULD STAND NEXT TO US AND
ASK THE GOVERNMENT, WHAT DO YOU
THINK YOU ARE DOING TO OUR
WOMEN.
THIS IS THEIR RIGHT, THEY DON'T
HAVE TO COVER THEIR FACES.
>> Reporter: AS THE TALIBAN
FOCUSES ON RESTRICTING WOMEN,
THE HUMANITARIAN CRISIS WORSENS.
NEARLY 20 MILLION PEOPLE FACE
ACUTE HUNGER THE UNITED NATIONS
SAID MON